frankie montos that man on the mound big
right-hander making his 31st start for
the green and gold this season coming
off a sparkling outing against the
angels
we kind of highlighted
seven innings just one hit
for frankie montos in that game kaif
it's been a while since we've seen
frankie get beyond that seventh inning
would love to see him start this series
out with a great deep run into this ball
game
and that's a ground ball on a hop to
chapman third baseman straightens up and
throws high and over the head of olsen
and it goes down by the sidewall el
touve will move to second a big turn in
second but will stop there and now while
two bay takes off for third throw across
the diamond and save altuve was
initially called out but chapman dropped
the ball and had a hickox
went with the safe sign usually
sure-handed and reliable matt chapman
taking his time and air mails it it's a
pretty good toss to get it over matt
olsen at first base
pays with the infield back without duvet
on third and nobody out
that hits bregman fastball clips them
and the astros will have runners on
first and third with nobody out as bonus
fastball hits bregman on the belt area
astros got action on first and third oh
one
and euler hits this in the air to right
center this should get the run and over
are martay and brown and as brown who
makes the catch altuve tagging the throw
home is cut off by olsen altuve scores
standing up and newly guriel sac fly
gives the astros a one nothing lead in
the first it's amazing how good he is at
that sacrifice flies is his forte now
here's the one-two frankie at the belt
and the pitch and that swung autumn has
a fastball by him at 98 and montas
limits the damage as the astros score
one and they leave one with the a's
coming up in the bottom half
the man they'll be facing tonight for
the houston astros brandon bilac
just his second start so spot start did
that earlier
in the year for framber valdez last time
around this time zach grinky hitting the
injured list with some neck stiffness
and they will hand the ball to mr bilac
belak to face harrison here's the pitch
by b back and that's swung on and
drilled back at third off the glove of
bregman it rolls into left field
harrison turning it first gonna put on
the brakes almost halfway to second you
know this ball is stalled right here now
marty steps up
here's the pitch and the ground ball on
the left for a base hit harrison goes to
second marta is singles to left and he
is that first and second and nobody out
the pitch
way high and over the head of canada
with the breaking ball and harrison
trying to go to third and the throw to
third is in time the throw initially
went to second by maldonado as harrison
was between second and third altuve
threw to bregman who got the out and
going to second on the play is marte the
2-2 swing and a mess struck him out on a
breaking ball away and the inning is
over so the a's had first and second
nobody out but they get nothing tucker
deep in the box the left-handed hitter
and now here's the o2 push to him swung
on and caught by botos on a vicious line
drive he reaches out the glove i'm not
sure if he caught it or the glove
actually just found the ball
that ball was blistered oh frankie with
the snag himself astronomed one nothing
out two they reached on an error his
last time up here's the 3-2
this is driven to left-center field and
deep going back on it camp and that's
gone
number 30 on the season for altuve and
it's 2-zip
a blast and left-center oh those boos
sound good
second career home run for altuve
against montas and he gets the 30 home
runs for the second time in his career
got a fastball he could handle here's
starling martay two on and one out a
couple of walks
hit hard korean dives can't get it left
center field and that's a hit
albus anders is going to come in to
score and all the way around the third
is harrison and the a's are on the board
it's 2-1
still only one out with runners at the
corners for matt olsen and the ball is
lying center field that's a base hit
harrison will score marty the third this
game is tied at two
matt olson all over that change up from
belak four consecutive a's hitters have
reached two runs in here's kenna
driven high in the air toward left
center
myers is over there and now coming
together with mccormick it ends up being
mccormick run comes in to score that's
marty it's a sacrifice live for cannon
it gives the a's a three to two lead
this is frankie montage goes to work on
the astros in the sixth inning and once
again he's throwing a great game
he's allowed one hit
and that was altuve's homer in the third
alvarez looked like he went he did so
jordan alvarez strikes out for the third
time tonight all three swinging frankie
montas has put jordan alvarez in a
pretzel
so two outs here's carlos correa
two boss two strikes nobody aboard
tucker's under correa awaits
frankie ready and it's on the way and
that's swung out of this throws it by
him
a one two three sixth inning and two
more canes for montas and we go to the
bottom of the sixth to bring up seth
brown who's bounced down five to left
here's the pitch and swung on a shot
into center field for a base hit
he has to have their sixth hit a simple
approach from seth brown here
see maldonado
wants this pitch just a little farther
down here
runner on the go the throw by martin
maldonado forget about it seth brown
gunned down first time he's been caught
stealing this year who else the machete
cuts him down
six innings eight strikeouts
remember his last start seven innings
one hit no walks seven strikeouts move
the runners up 90 feet couple guys in
scoring position now for the astros and
it's grabbed by frankie montos what a
plan he throws to first
to work frankie
so here is jose l tuvay kicks and
delivers at a slider's lift to the left
coming on forward as tony kemp he'll
make a cap high catch big clap by
frankie mo toss and the inning is over
two on and nobody out no problem
two balls and two strikes
runner holds the pitches looped into
center field that's going to drop for it
kept around second he's hustling the
third the play for myers is gonna be the
second base as tony slides in head first
to third
the challenge myers saw the play in
front of him did not break stride if the
a's are threatening with runners at
first and third and nobody out for elvis
andrews
now martay stands in no place to go but
home one out of the inning first pitch
demarte is hit fair down the third
baseline it's headed for the corner one
run scores two runs score
harrison the third he'll stop there and
the a's lead it five to two
scarlet marty gonna ride that wave no
place to go but home ace is loaded one
ball two strikes and here he comes with
a slider hit high in the air deep left
back as mccormick to the track at the
wall it's a grand slam for chad pinder
chad pinder unloads on brooks raleigh
deep into the night
harrison marte and kenna
wait for pinder at home plate and the
a's have busted it open they lead nine
to two
[Applause]
softly hit center field and a dive and
it's off the glove of myers
one runs gonna score everybody moves up
rbi single for marte it's 11 to two
driven to left mccormick back still
going back and he cannot get it it's off
the wall one run scores two runs score
marty scores olson has cleared the bases
it's 14-2
jose siri is going to bat for altuve
and he got him swinging so
acevedo works hard but he keeps the
astros
off the board in the ninth inning in
game one of this
three-game series goes to the athletics
so they bounce back nicely after a tough
series
against the mariners